charles zass ian scher alsacien nous
voici à la fin de la première semaine du
déconfinement nous vivons chacun dans
nos vies et collectivement une période
inédite fait de doute et d'inquiétude
mais aussi d'attentes et d'espoirs
vous le savez l'alsace est encore classé
rouge
le virus circule de plus en plus
faiblement et c'est une bonne nouvelle
mais nous savons aussi que la situation
dans les hôpitaux restent encore tendue
nous devons donc aborder cette période
de sortie progressive du confinement
plus que jamais avec grande prudence
mais aussi en confiance et en restant
solidaires avec grande prudence parce
que nous devons continuer à respecter
strictement les gestes barrières et
mesures de protection les distribution
de masques offert à chaque haut rhinois
par le conseil départemental nos
intercommunalités l'origine locales et
l'état ont commencé la semaine dernière
et elle se poursuivre cette semaine et
continueront dans les prochains jours
avec le soutien précieux de l'armée nous
n'avons pas le droit de baisser la garde
c'est à ce prix et seulement à ce prix
que nous pourrons encore aller plus loin
dans la réduction des contraintes qui
pèsent sur nos vies
cette sortie du confinement nous devons
aussi l'aborder en confiance en
confiance parce que vous pouvez compter
sur la mobilisation de votre conseil
départemental
une mobilisation de tous les instants de
ses élus et de ses équipes
hier j'ai visité les chantiers du
collège de saint-amarin et du barrage de
kruth également en travaux
ces deux programmes de travaux de 13 et
11,2 millions d'euros témoigne de
l'engagement de votre département pour
poursuivre ces grands projets
d'investissement dans tous les
territoires
malgré la crise c'est un soutien
indispensable ou btp et une marque de
confiance en l'avenir en l'avenir de
notre jeunesse et
nos territoires ce soutien à nos
entreprises mais aussi à nos commerces
aux territoires aux associations aux
personnes directement touchées par la
crise est une absolue nécessité
après la crise sanitaire nous avons en
effet à relever collectivement un double
défi un défi économique est un défi
social
c'est dans ce sens que nous avons adopté
ce matin un plan ambitieux de soutien de
3,5 millions d'euros
enfin je continue une mobilisation de
chaque instant pour ouvrir nos
frontières avec l'allemagne et la suisse
nous ne pouvons pas accepter de
continuer à être séparés par henri d'eau
sanitaire qui n'a plus lieu d'être
si l'alsace a réussi à faire front c'est
grâce à un esprit de solidarité
extraordinaire sens étant très bon rien
lui était possible et il est aujourd'hui
fondamental que cet esprit de solidarité
se poursuivre car la solidarité notre
force c'est tous ensemble que nous
surmonterons cette épreuve